>>> THIRD QUARTER, HERE WE GO.
EVERYBODY GOOD ON DRINK?
JAKE?
>> OH, NO MAN, I GOT WORK EARLY
TOMORROW.
I THINK I'M GOOD.
>> CUT TO YOU 40 BEERS LATER
BEING LIKE, "OH, ACTUALLY I
THINK I'M GOING TO BE USING THAT
SICK DAY."
>> YEAH, CUT TO YOUR WIFE
TOMORROW MORNING BEING LIKE,
"ARE YOU DRUNK?"
AND YOU'RE LIKE, "NO."
>> OH, COME ON, MAN, THAT'S NOT
A LATE HIT.
>> I KNOW, THIS LEAGUE IS SO
SOFT NOW.
IT'S RIDICULOUS.
>> CUT TO HE'S SO DRUNK HE'S GOT
LIKE A GRENADE LAUNCHER NOW.
AND HE'S LIKE, "NEVER MIND THE
KIDS.
SAVE THE BURRITOS."
>> WHAT?
>> FROM EARLIER.
JAKE, HE'S JUST, LIKE, SO DRUNK.
>> A GRENADE LAUNCHER?
>> MAN, I WANT WHATEVER HE'S
SMOKING.
>> I'M JUST MESSING.
>> I THINK I'M GOING GRAB THOSE
BUFFALO WINGS, ACTUALLY.
I'M STARVING.
♪♪♪
♪ WHY CAN'T I KEEP THE JOKE
GOING? ♪
♪ THE JOKE GOING? ♪
♪ WHEN I RIP WITH MY FRIENDS
I JUST SLOW THINGS DOWN ♪
♪ SLOW THINGS DOWN ♪
♪ I ALWAYS JUMP IN REALLY
CONFIDENT BUT NOBODY LAUGHS AT
WHAT I SAY ♪
♪ I TRY SO HARD, BUT WHAT I SAY
JUST DOESN'T MAKE SENSE ♪
♪ IT SOUNDS SO GOOD IN MY HEAD
BUT THEN MY ENERGY IS WEIRD ♪
♪ I'M THE GUY WHO KILLS THE BIT
KILLS THE BIT, KILLS THE BIT ♪
♪ YES, I'M ALWAYS KILLING THE
BIT, KILLING THE BIT, KILLING
THE BIT ♪
♪ NOW ONCE AGAIN EVERYBODY'S
LAUGHING ♪
♪ I BETTER SAY SOMETHING COOL
AND HILARIOUS ♪
>> CUT TO, LIKE, A GIANT MUTATED
BUFFALO WING WITH BOXING GLOVES.
LIKE, AND IN THIS CORNER,
WEIGHING IN AT 1,000 POUNDS,
JONNY BUFFALO.
>> WHAT?
>> THE BUFFALO WINGS YOU GUYS
WERE TALKING ABOUT.
>> THAT WAS LIKE FIVE MINUTES
AGO.
>> OH!
>> DUDE.
>> GARRETT'S RIGHT.
I WANT WHAT I'M SMOKING.
>> BRYAN, LISTEN, WE LIKE YOU,
MAN.
YOU'RE A GREAT GUY.
SO I SAY THIS WITH LOVE --
YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE FUNNY.
>> ALL RIGHT, STEVE.
>> NO, SERIOUSLY, MAN.
LIKE, IT'S OKAY TO JUST LISTEN.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO ADD ANYTHING.
>> RIGHT.
CUT TO ME MAKING LIKE A THOUSAND
MORE JOKES.
>> I'M SORRY.
AM I MISSING SOMETHING?
WHAT IS THIS "CUT TO" THING?
>> WE WERE DOING IT EARLIER.
>> MAYBE JUST GIVE IT A REST.
>> YEAH.
I THINK WE'RE ALL A LITTLE
"CUT TO-ED" OUT.
>> FOR SURE.
CUT TO ME MAKING ANOTHER
"CUT TO" JOKE.
>> OKAY, THAT'S NOT BAD.
>> YEAH, THAT ONE WAS PRETTY
GOOD.
♪ I'M THE GUY WHO NAILED THE
BIT, NAILED THE BIT, NAILED THE
BIT ♪
♪ AND NOW THAT I PROVEN MYSELF
I'M FINALLY JUST ONE OF THE
GUYS ♪
>> HEY, STEVE, BEER ALERT.
THINK FAST.
>> OH!
[ BLEEP ].
>> OH.
I THINK I MIGHT JUST BOUNCE.
♪♪♪